Hallo, Blut ist mein Name. Ich bin die Suchtändiker, als ich für Sie und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das an einem Nestgespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne, Frau Doktor.
Ja, sehr gut. Bevor Sie mir Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, möchte ich einige Personiedaten erfragen.
Danach werde ich direkt zu Ihren Beschwerden übergehen. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Philipp Holzmann.
Holzmann, könnten Sie Ihre Nachname bestrabieren?
H-O-L-Z-M-A-N
Okay, danke.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Holzmann?
Ich bin 70 Jahre alt.
71? Sind Sie genau geboren?
29. Dezember 51.
Okay.
Und was machen Sie, Herr Holzmann?
Ich bin Rentner.
Seit wann?
Seit ungefähr 64 Jahren bin ich in den Ruhestand gegangen.
64?
Okay.
Sind Sie für Ruflässe?
Bitte, Entschuldigung.
Dann tun Sie mal wieder.
Ich habe das schon gemacht.
Könnten Sie mich hören jetzt?
Ja, nochmal bitte.
Sind Sie für Ruflässe?
Ich habe das immer noch nicht verstanden.
Tut mir leid.
Ja, ich meine, sind Sie früher als üblich?
Ja, ein Jahr früher.
Ja, wieso?
Nee, ich hatte ein Angebot von meiner Firma.
Und dann habe ich das angenommen.
Ja, ich habe das verstanden.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie, Herr Holzmann?
Ich habe in den letzten 30 Jahren viel Gewicht verloren.
Ich habe 8-10 kg.
Ich habe jetzt nur noch 70 kg.
Meine Körpergröße war einmal 1,75 m.
Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen einen Rundrücken bekommen.
Ich habe gesehen, dass ich 5-6 cm kleiner geworden bin.
Okay, verstehe.
Ich habe jetzt noch etwas gewicht.
Ich habe jetzt noch etwas kleiner geworden bin auch.
Okay, verstehe.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe Kinder, ja.
Wie viele Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Meine Kinder sind der Sohn ist 45 und die Tochter ist 45.
Ja, und die Tochter 41 Jahre alt.
Okay, sind Sie vererratet?
Ja, ich meine meine Kinder.
Entschuldigung, ich konnte nicht verstehen.
Meinen Sie mich oder meinen Sie meine Kinder?
Okay.
Also mit vererratet, haben Sie gefragt.
Also ich bin vererratet, ja.
Nein, nein, ich meine sie.
Okay, gut.
Herr Holzmann, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Was führt Sie so um?
Ja, Walter, das sind viele Probleme.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wo ich anfangen soll.
Ich fange vielleicht mal an,
aber ich habe mich ziemlich schwach fühle,
kraftlos abgeschlagen.
Seit einem halben Jahr, kann ich sagen,
geht es körperlich bergab mit mir.
Und das Hauptproblem, was jetzt zugenommen hat,
ist eigentlich, dass ich starke Rückenschmerzen habe.
Die habe ich schon seit drei bis vier Monaten.
Aber in den letzten zwei, drei Wochen haben die doch stark,
sehr stark zugenommen.
So dass die Schmerzmedikamenten, die ich vom Hausatz bekommen habe,
auch nicht mehr helfen.
Das sind so die Hauptprobleme,
aber es gibt noch ein paar andere Probleme,
die ich Ihnen erzählen kann, wenn Sie möchten.
Ja, natürlich.
Könnten Sie auch die anderen Bescheiden erzählen?
Ja, dann muss ich ein bisschen ausholen vielleicht.
Und zwar, wie kann ich sagen,
also ich habe jetzt auch,
viel Wasser eingelagert in den Beinen,
in den Füßen, unter Schinkel,
auch fast ein bisschen ober Schinkel.
Und da hatte ich auch vom Hausarzt
Entwässungsmedikamente bekommen.
Und darunter habe ich jetzt vor zwei Wochen
ungefähr auch das rechte Bein stark angeschwollen.
Hausarzt hat Ultraschall gemacht,
sagt es, eine Trombose dazu gekommen.
Aber insgesamt die Wassereinlagung in den Beinen
sind immer noch auf beiden Seiten trotzdem noch vorhanden.
Und ja, also ich habe auch gemerkt,
dass ich weniger Wasser gelassen habe,
obwohl ich diese Entwässungstabletten genommen habe.
Der Orin ist von der Menge weniger.
Und wenn ich Wasser lassen muss,
dann merke ich, dass das so richtig auch schäumt.
Also der Orin schäumt,
aber ich habe das nicht mehr.
Und dann kann ich vielleicht noch sagen,
dass auch vor drei Monaten ich auch beim Hausarzt war,
wegen Beschwerden im Unterbauch,
linken Unterbauch.
Da hat der Hausarzt auch Ultraschall gemacht,
hat gesagt, es ist eine Divertikel Entzündung
und hat mir dann Antibiotika gegeben.
Und darunter ist das auch besser geworden.
Und das ist auch besser geworden.
Und er hat auch gesagt,
dass ich ein bisschen Blutarmut habe,
dass es am ehesten von der Infektion kommt.
Oder Entzündung kommt,
hat mir da auch Eisentabletten aufgeschrieben.
Das sind so die wichtigsten Probleme, die ich habe.
Wissen Sie die Werte von Blutarmut?
Nein, das weiß ich nicht, aber...
Aber Sie haben gesagt, leicht, oder?
Das war jetzt nicht so stark, hat er gesagt.
Er hat auch Eisen gewissen im Blut.
Er meinte, das Eisen wäre ein bisschen niedrig.
Er hat mir deswegen Eisentabletten gegeben.
Aber wie hoch der Wert war, kann ich nicht sagen.
Aber ich glaube schon, dass der immer noch niedrig ist,
weil ich bin ziemlich blass im Gesicht und in den Augen.
Und wann war diese linken Unterbauchschmerzung?
Also ungefähr vor drei Monaten war das gewesen.
Aber es wird besser jetzt, jetzt habe ich keine Beschwerden mehr im Bauch.
Hatten Sie noch andere Anstägungen der Krankheiten in diesen sechs Monaten?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich habe gemerkt, ich habe jetzt häufige Infektionen.
Das war früher auch nicht so gewesen.
Ich hatte jetzt in den letzten halben Jahren mindestens zwei oder dreimal
eine schwere Pornchitis gehabt,
wo der Haushalt mir auch an die Würde verschrieben hat.
Ich habe auch mal vor einer Zeit auch mal eine Infektion der Handblase,
also Blasenentzündung.
Das hatte ich früher auch nicht so gehabt.
Das ist richtig.
Also ich habe häufige Infektionen jetzt im letzten halben Jahr auch bemerkt.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie auch Blutungsprobleme?
Ich meine zum Beispiel in Ihrem Haut,
haben Sie Farbeveränderungen bemerkt?
Können Sie einfach mit kleinen Verletzungen Blutung gehabt?
Das kann ich jetzt so nicht sagen.
Sie haben uns schon gesagt, dass Ihre Gewicht ein bisschen vermindert ist.
Aber wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Können Sie normal essen?
Eigentlich ja, würde ich sagen.
Appetit ist jetzt nicht so das Problem.
Wie eine, Sie Sie?
So wie immer.
Ich habe mich jetzt auch in Ehren umgestellt.
Ich mache das wie früher.
Ich meine, Sie essen Fleisch, Gemüse, Obst, alles.
Trinken Sie aus reichend Wasser?
Ich habe schon darauf geachtet, dass ich da viel trinke.
Aber so zwei Liter war das mindestens gewesen.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass da Urin nicht so viel ist, den ich lassen muss.
Wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, ist sie trinken genug viel Wasser.
Eigentlich ja.
Aber es bleibt im Körper.
Ja, Sie lassen nicht viel Urin.
Im Teil gleist du Wasser, das ist zu wenig.
Ich finde ja, weil ich merke auch, dass das in den Körper hängen bleibt,
ich merke auch, dass ich das Wasser habe.
Ich habe überall Wasser im Körper.
Haben Sie Urin Blut bemerkt?
Nein, nur dass es sehr geschäumt hat, habe ich gemerkt.
Und wie oft müssen Sie Wasser lassen?
Es kommt auch an, wie viel ich trinke.
Ich habe bis jetzt nicht darauf geachtet, wie oft.
Müssen Sie in der Nacht auch abwasser lassen?
Ja, ein bis zwei Mal.
Ich habe auch eine Prosta dafür größt, aber das ist schon seit Jahren bei mir.
Aber das ist immer gleich seit Jahren?
Ja, immer ein, zwei Mal.
Ein bis zwei Mal maximal, ja.
Wie ist Ihre Stuhlgang?
Haben Sie Veränderung bemerkt?
Haben Sie Versturkung oder Durchfall?
Der ist eigentlich bis auf die Farbe, der ist schwarz.
Aber das ist seitdem ich diese Eisen-Tabletten nehme,
vorher war das nicht so.
Okay, für halt keine.
Haben Sie Hautfarbe Veränderungen bemerkt?
Also ich bin Blass, ja.
Das haben mir auch andere Leute gesagt, dass ich eine Blassefarbe bekommen habe.
Leiden Sie unter Fieber?
Es ist besonders in dieser sechsten Monate,
ich meine außer die Ernsteckende Krankheiten.
Ja, kann ich nicht sagen, nein, sonst habe ich keine Fieber.
Schwitzen Sie in der Nacht?
Kann ich nicht sagen, nein.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Vorerkrankungen erfahren.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelchen chronischen Krankheiten?
Also, ich hatte vor, ich weiß noch, ob es als chronische Krankheit gilt,
ich hatte vor etwa 25 Jahren mal eine Krankheit,
die heißt Morbis-Hotschkin.
Und da habe ich damals Schirmotterapie bekommen
und habe auch eine Bestrahlung bekommen.
Aber das war dann alles gut geheilt
und hat dann auch die Kontrolluntersuchungen gehabt.
Und das war dann alles in Ordnung.
Also da habe ich keine Bemerk gehabt, das war vor 25 Jahren etwa.
Dann habe ich Ihnen schon gesagt,
dass ich diese Prostatorvergrößerung habe.
Und das habe ich noch für Probleme.
Ja, vielleicht ist das auch wichtig.
Ich habe es so, Problem mit den Beinen gehabt,
so Schmerzen in den Füßen, so brennende Schmerzen.
Da hatte mich mein Haus als auch zum Neurologen geschickt.
Ich habe auch eine Polyneuropathie festgestellt.
Das war auch so vor ungefähr ein halben, dreiviertel Jahr.
Und da habe ich nämlich auch Medikamente ein dafür.
Weiche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Das heißt Prigabalin, heißt das Medikament.
Darunter ist ein bisschen besser geworden.
Haben Sie auch Zuckerkrankheit?
Nein, Zucker ist nie festgestellt worden bei mir.
Problem mit Herz, haben Sie?
Auch nicht.
Und wann war der letzte Kontroll für Hodgkin?
Ich habe damals nach der Therapie fünf Jahre lang die Kontrollen gemacht.
Und als das dann gut war, haben wir dann die Kontrollen beendet.
Ich war jetzt über 20 Jahre nicht mehr zur Kontrolle.
Ich hatte auch keine Probleme mehr.
Sind Sie vollständig gebt?
Meinen Sie jetzt Corona?
Ja, ich meine allgemein die Routine-Impfungen und zusätzlich natürlich Corona.
Weiß ich nicht genau.
Die Impfungen sind auch schon ziemlich lange her bei mir.
Also Tetanus und so, das ist auch mindestens zehn oder 15 Jahre.
Aber Corona bin ich jetzt dreimal geimpft worden.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Nein, ich hatte keine Operation bisher.
Und reagieren Sie auf etwas allergisch?
Ich habe auch keine Probleme gehabt bisher.
Haben Sie auch Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, also habe ich keine Probleme damit.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Schmerzen in Beine haben.
Und Sie nehmen dagegen Medikamente.
Jetzt haben Sie immer noch Probleme?
Also weniger, aber da muss ich auch sagen, sind die anderen Schmerzen
jetzt viel deutlicher im Vordergrund,
sodass ich die anderen Beschwerden jetzt vernachlässigt habe.
Also die Rückenschmerzen sind viel mehr.
Deswegen habe ich die anderen Beschwerden jetzt auch gar nicht so zur Kenntnis genommen.
Wagen Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Fühlen Sie sich hoffnunglos?
Oder wie ist Ihre Stimmung allgemein?
Meine Stimmung ist nicht so gut wegen der Probleme jetzt,
die ich habe vor allem wegen der Schmerzen, ist meine Stimmung schlecht.
Aber früher war alles normal.
Das Hauptsicht durch die Schmerzen,
dass ich jetzt meine Stimmung schlecht ist.
Nun kommen wir zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich habe mal geraucht, ich habe aufgehört vor ungefähr 10 Jahren.
Wie lange und wie oft hat dann Sie geraucht?
Mit Unterbrechungen kann man sagen, wenn ich mit ungefähr 18 angefangen habe, bis 60,
vielleicht mal 5 Jahre ohne Zigaretten,
etwa 35 Jahre, wenn man das zusammenrechnet.
35 Jahre.
Wie viel Packung pro Tag haben Sie?
Nicht so viel, aber halb bis ganzes Päckchen.
Also eher auch mal halb bis Päckchen, so 10 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Gelegentlich, nicht regelmäßig.
Wie meinen Sie mit gelegentlich?
Ja, bei Anlässen, in Feieräste oder so was.
Vielleicht haben wir im Monat vielleicht.
Haben Sie schon mal Drogen probiert?
Nein.
Ich würde gerne nach Ihrer Familiengeschichte fragen,
sind bei Ihren Eltern irgendwelchen Krankheiten bekannt?
Ich überlege, mein Vater ist Schlaganfall gestorben.
Meine Mutter hatte auch bei Krankheiten Zucker und Bluthochdruck.
Ich glaube, die ist letztlich auch an Herzversagen gestorben.
Aber ganz genau kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe zwei Geschwister, ja.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die sind so, dass ich weiß, gesund, aber man kann keine größeren Krankheiten.
Ja, und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie zwei Kinder haben.
Sind Ihre Kinder auch gesund?
Die sind gesund, ja.
Ich denke, ich habe die wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Jetzt möchte ich eine kurze Zusammenfassung geben.
Seit sechs Monaten haben Sie Müdigkeit, Abgeschlägenheit.
Sie haben ungefähr acht bis zehn Kilo abgenommen.
Ja, richtig.
Sie denken auch, dass Sie kleiner geworden sind.
Ja, ich meine große.
Sie haben Wasser und Wasseranlagung in den Beinen.
Sie haben auch Polyneuropathie, aber mit diesen neuen Beschwerden
sind die Schmerzen schlechter geworden.
Hab ich recht?
Die in Beinen sind nicht mehr das Problem, sondern die Rückenschmerzen sind das Hauptproblem.
Ich habe es falsch ausgedrückt.
Vor drei Monaten hatten Sie eine Infektion.
Und in diesen sechs Monaten haben Sie sehr öfter ansteckende Krankheiten
im Fall gleich so früh gehabt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es ansteckend war, aber ich hatte Infektionen gehabt.
Infektionen, meine ich.
Sie hatten früher Morbus Sporting, aber es war schon gut behandelt
und jetzt ohne Befund.
Vielen Dank, Herr Schultzmann.
Jetzt um eine richtige.
Schöne, eine Sache habe ich vergessen.
Ich hatte früher nie Probleme im Blutdruck.
Seit ein, zwei Wochen habe ich hohe Blutdruckwert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das wichtig für Sie ist.
Wie hoch?
Teilweise mit der oberen Wert, 170, 180 und der untere Wert, so um 100 sogar.
Hatte ich früher auch nie Probleme gehabt mit.
Das ist auch sehr wichtig für uns.
Vielen Dank für diese Information.
Okay.
Jetzt sollten wir ein paar Tests durchführen.
Und natürlich einen Kölb-Palle herunterrufen ist sehr wichtig.
Wenn die Ergebnisse vorliegen, können wir über die weitere Beda-Spray.
Jetzt haben Sie noch Fragen?
Momentan nicht mehr.
Vielen Dank, Frau Doktor.
Sehr gerne.
Gut, gibt es Fragen aus dem Auditorium oder Information?
Was hätten Sie noch gefragt?
Jetzt alles gefragt worden, was wichtig ist.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Ich habe keine Atemnot, nein.
Können Sie fliegen, ohne Atemnot zu bekommen?
Ja, kann ich.
Haben Sie die Veränderung Ihrer Stimme oder Ihre Haare bemerkt?
Nein, aber Sie haben nicht nach den Medikamenten gefragt, glaube ich.
Ich habe gefragt, ich glaube aber nicht allgemein.
Haben Sie auch alles gesagt?
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, ich habe nicht, aber allgemein, ich glaube, ich habe das nicht gefragt.
Ich habe gefragt, gegen nur Ihre Beschwerden.
Soll ich Ihnen sagen, was ich alles nehmen habe?
Ja, das wäre sehr nüßlich.
Also, ich nehme Prigabalin, haben Sie aufgeschrieben?
Ja, Sie haben es.
Dann habe ich, wegen der ÖD, habe ich Thorazer mitbekommen vom Hausarzt.
Eine morgens.
Ich nehme eine Duo-Dat ein für die Prostata.
Noch einmal bitte für gegen Prostata.
Duo-Dat.
Genau.
Kombinationspräparat bei Prostata über Blasie.
Dann nehme ich, noch wegen der Thrombose, spritze ich Inno-Hab,
eine spritze 0,7 Milliliter pro Tag, Subkutan.
Gegen die Schmerzen nehme ich 4 mal 30 Tropfen Novalgin
und ich nehme noch Eisentabletten ein,
Ferrosanoldodinal, 2 Stück pro Tag, 100 Milligramm.
Das sind die Medikamente, die ich nehme.
Okay, noch andere Kommentare oder andere Fragen, die wichtig werden?
Ich glaube, es war eigentlich ziemlich ausführlich,
die Anomlese gemacht worden.
Oder gibt es noch jemanden, der eine Frage hat?
An den Patienten.
Bitte schön.
Die Schmerzen hätten Sie noch ein bisschen genauer fragen können,
ob es ein Trauma war.
Oder, wenn die auftreten, so weiter.
Ja.
Können Sie bitte sagen, oder zeigen Sie mir, wo die Schmerzen am Stext sind?
Also in der gesamten Wirbelsäule, von oben bis unten.
Ja.
Können Sie bitte die Schmerzen genauer beschreiben,
sind die Schmerzen eher, boom, drücken, stecken.
Beides Stächen, dumpf, sehr wechselhaft, auch mal einschießend.
Ja.
Und wie ich, wie ich,
wie ich das nicht mehr auf einer Kalafon sehen.
Ach bis 9.
Ja.
Und Sie haben gesagt, eine Herzrasen,
bitte können Sie mir...
Herzrasen habe ich nicht gesagt, ne?
Nicht gesagt?
Ja.
Da habe ich mich, also da habe ich mich nicht erinnern,
habe ich keinen Problem mehr.
Die Schmerzen sind vor allen Dingen, wenn ich aufgehend und laufe,
im Liegen sind sie weniger.
Und dann kann man noch fragen, ob ich,
können Sie fragen, ob ich neurologische Ausfälle habe, ja?
Ja.
Hat er aber nicht.
Grippeln.
Also Grippeln hat er, aber wie in der Polnöropathie schon seit...
Ich habe auch das gedacht und deshalb habe ich das nicht gefragt.
Sie haben schon Polnöropathie.
Vielleicht können wir auch fragen, ob es schlechter oder weniger.
Oder Sie können sagen, ob auch die Muskeln schwächer sind,
ob er, sag ich mal, seitensdifferenz hat.
Auf eine Paräse zum Beispiel, ja.
Ja.
Warum hat er Blutarmut?
Das muss Frau Doktor sagen.
Ja, ich...
Ich kann nicht genau sagen, wie viel aber vor 3, 4 Monaten war es ungefähr gewesen, der Test.
Ja, ich kann nicht 100%ig sehr sagen,
aber ich denke, dieser Patient kann eine chronische Renalinspecienz haben.
Auch dieser Patient kann Mutbilmielung auch haben.
In diesem Alter sollte man daran denken.
Sehr gut. Das war die Diagnose.
Haben Sie schon getroffen?
Ja.
Aber das ist nicht einfach, weil Sie haben verschiedene Symptomkomplexe,
aber der Patient hat ein Multibus-Chemäolomus, richtig?
Mhm.
Sehr gut.
Haben Sie Orgoreuche? Orgoreuche hat da nichts gemerkt.
Nein. Warum fragen Sie nach Orgoreuchen?
Warum wollen Sie das wissen?
Wer hat das gefragt? Orgoreuche?
Warum ist das wichtig, Orgoreuche?
Ich kann Ihnen nicht genau sagen, warum Orgoreuche wichtig werden.
Na gut, okay. Dann können wir die Fragen...
Tinnitus, oder? Bitte.
Tinnitus?
Tinnitus.
Haben Sie Belaufläck?
Hat die Kollegen gefragt? Hat keiner Hautfläcken gehabt? Nein.
Hat sie aber gefragt? Ja.
Gut, dann gehen wir zur Obersvorstellung, ja?
Ja, okay, ich werde versuchen.
Das ist zum ersten Mal. Deshalb bin ich ein bisschen aufgeregt darüber.
Danke, Herr Oberarzt.
Hallo Herr Oberarzt.
Jetzt habe ich heute einen neuen Fall aufgenommen,
den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Es handelt sich um Phleps Holthrand.
Er ist 70 Jahre alt.
Er ist 70 kg und 100.
Er ist 75 cm,
170 cm ungefähr.
Er hat sich wegen seit sechs Monaten bestehende Müdigkeit,
Fetik und Gewichtverlust vorgestellt.
Der Patient leigt über auch
Beinodäme.
Er hat keine Nocturine,
nur ein oder zweimal, aber wie üblich,
hat er gesagt.
Er hat Blassfarbe,
auch Erhabenämie, laut die Werte von Hausarzt.
Vor Erkrankungen hatte er Morbus Hoczkin,
aber das war schon mit 25 Jahren.
Es war schon 100 Jahre alt.
Morbus Hoczkin hat eine komplette Remission.
Ja, eine komplette Remission.
Er hat Besüglich der Medikation,
2x pro Tag,
1x pro Tag,
und 2x pro Tag.
Letzter Zeit hatte er eine TFT Ventrum-Bose.
Er nimmt auch Inno-Hept-Subcuton,
0,7 pro Tag.
Der Patient leckt über auch
die starken Rückenschmeizung.
Die Schmerzen seien 8 bis 9 auf
einer Skala von 0 bis 10.
Die Schmerzen seien im Liegen
besser im Vergleich beim Stehen.
Die Atomnot
oder die andere
Herzkreislaufbeschwerden wurden verneint.
Sie haben keine
Karchikardie, Bredikate oder andere
Herz-Rizmus-Störungen.
Zusätzlich haben er in letzter Zeit
ein bisschen erhöhte Blutdruckwerte,
ungefähr 170 bis 100 Millimeter.
Er hat auch erklärt,
dass in dieser Zeit er sehr oft
Infektionen habe.
Er trinkt genug, aber
das Wasser lassen sei nicht so viel wie
die trinkende Wasser.
Die Vegetative
sei unaufwendig, bis
nur diese Gewitzverlust.
An Vorerkrankungen habe ich gesagt,
Morbis Horschkin,
und sozusagen habe er auch Polyneuropathie.
Das war nur in ein paar Monaten
Polyneuropathie.
Die andere chronische Krankheit
ist Urban Fair Nines.
Ich habe die wichtige
Befunde gesagt.
Alles klar.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstagnose?
Laut an amnistischen Angaben
begleiten Sie sich
die Risikofaktoren.
Ich gehe von
Multiplmellum hin.
Aber
sozusagen sollte auch eine
Renalinspräsent ausgeschlossen werden.
Mit diesem Altau und
Befunden sind Multiplmellum sehr häufig.
Deshalb sollte ein Elektroforo
durchgeführt werden.
Diese Proteine
zu entdecken.
Je nach Befunde
können wir die weitere Schritte planen.
Kurz bevor wir zu den Diagnostiken.
Welche Informationen aus der Ananese
haben Sie denn für Anlass an
ein Multiplmellum zu denken?
Rückenschmerzen ist wichtig.
Sonst habe ich
Renalprobleme.
Wir haben auch Anämie.
Natürlich haben sie
sehr oft Infektionen.
Das bedeutet,
entweder weniger
Leukositen oder
unfunktionale Leukositen.
Deshalb hat
Panzitopenie und mit Rückenschmerzen
und Altau.
Er hat es normale Leukositen.
Warum hat er eine erhöhte Infektanfälligkeit?
Ich denke,
diese Leukositen funktionieren nicht ganz normal.
Warum?
Warum ist das Problem?
Warum kriegen die Infektionen?
Ein Antikabermangel.
Die Monoglobulinmangel.
Die Monoglobulinmangel stimmt nicht.
Die haben zu viele Monoglobulinmangel.
Aber die funktionieren nicht.
Deswegen Antikabermangel-Syndrom.
Das ist der Grund für die gehäuften Infektionen.
Warum hat der eine Anämie?
Weil die
die Monoglobulinmangel
schädigt die Niere.
Sie meinen, es ist eine Rennale-Anämie.
Ja.
Die anderen Ursache haben die Anämie.
Die Rennale-Anämie.
Die Knochenmarken.
Das ist nicht nur die Anämie.
Sie sind nachher damit, die Kollegen nicht weiß.
Dann rufe ich sie auf.
Ja, diese erhöhte
und nun dann Funktionen,
die gelobt Schädigten Knochenmark.
Was ist das Problem beim Knochenmark?
Ist das durch die Monoglobulin gestört?
Was ist das?
mir nichts zu haben, die Nieren von dieser Hypergulinenie geschädigt, aber die Knochenmark produziert schon diese, ich meine diese nonfunktionen.
Was ist der Grund, oder was ist die Pathophysiologie bei einer reinen Anämie?
Neine Anämie, Erdroprotein.
Das ist erwidrig, das kann eine Produktion sein.
Was kann bei Myolom sein?
Die Fälen der Sälen sterben nicht ab und produzieren immer mehr Absterben von Sälen.
Welche Sälen?
Die Sälen, die nicht richtig funktionieren, aber ich kann mir nichts sehr gut erzählen.
Was passiert denn bei Myolom? Was ist denn da das Problem bei Myolom? Was ist das für eine Krankheit?
Das ist eine Krankheit, die Apoptosis ist gestürzt.
Das ist ja eine bösartige Krankheit, welche Sälen sind denn bösartig bei dem multiple Myolom?
Welche Sälen produzieren denn die?
Plasmacellen.
Was machen die Plasmacellen, wenn sie bösartig sind?
Sie multiplieren immer und sterben nicht ab. Normalerweise in einer Zeit sollten die non-funktionellen Absterben, aber hier...
Die wachsen mal weiter, ja?
Ja.
Und was machen Sie, wenn Sie weiter wachsen?
Sie schädigen die ganzen Körper, die z.B. nähern die Knochen.
Warum, wenn die Knochen zerstört?
Weil gibt es immer mehr Reproduktion in Knochenmark.
Richtig, ja. Also die vermehren sich im Knochenmark hauptsächlich, gell?
Ja.
Und wenn Sie sich im Knochenmark vermehren, was ist dann das Problem für die normalen Knochenmark-Sälen?
Die haben weniger Platz.
Ja.
Das heißt, sie bekommen eine Knochenmarkinsuffizienz, weil das Plasmocytom das Knochenmark infiltriert, ja?
Also wird die Erythropoese dadurch behindert, weil kein genug Platz ist im Knochenmark?
Ja?
Das ist die Pathophysiologie dahinter bei der Anämie vom Myolom, ja?
Also das ist eigentlich eine Verdrängung des Knochenmarks durch Plasmacellen.
Deswegen kann nicht genug produziert werden, ja?
Okay, das ist zur Anämie. Was gab es noch für Hinweise aus der Anämie, die auf Sie...
Ja, höchste Blutrufdruck.
Ja, warum?
Kann auch ein Hinweis sein.
Die habe gedacht, ein Hinweis.
Auf Morbus, auf einem Myolom, oder warum?
Nee, ich habe gedacht, dass Renal die Wirkung annäheren kann, die sehr höchste Blutdruck verursachen.
Richtig, genau. Ja.
Ja.
Gut, was gab es noch für Hinweise, die Sie dazu gebracht haben zu denken, dass es ein Myolom ist aus der Anämie?
Haben wir schon vieles genannt, also Renal...
Rombose, ich glaube tief, wenn Rombose...
Rombose kann sein, ja.
Weil die Hypalviscosite im Blut ist erhöht.
Richtig, sehr gut.
Das kann es auch sein.
Genau, sehr gut.
Und dann hat jemand geschrieben, hier, was ich auch wichtig finde, Körpergröße vermindert, ja?
Genau.
Warum ist das wichtig?
Ja, wir haben schon gesagt, Nordenmark ist geschädigt und...
Das bedeutet ein Osteolysis und deshalb ist die Patientin kleiner geworden.
Weil die Wirbelkörper zusammenbrechen, ja?
Ja.
Sinterungsfaktoren, ja, sehr gut.
Gut, was ist mit der Polyneuropathie?
Hat das etwas mit dem Myolom zu tun?
Oder ist es unabhängig davon?
Ja, ich hatte auch dafür den Ehren gedacht, mit weniger Funktionen.
Die Patientinnen mit chronischer Renalinuffizienz können Polyneuropathie haben.
Deshalb habe ich gedacht, das kann auch wegen Niereninsuffizienz sein.
Aber ansonsten weiß ich nichts.
Ja, also es kann auch mit dem Myolom zu tun haben, hat auch jemand geschrieben, hier,
Polyneuropathie durch die zirkulierten Paraproteine, ja?
Das ist möglich durch diese Ablagung der Leichtketten vor allem, zum Beispiel, ja?
Gut, okay.
Was gab es noch für Hinweise aus der Anämnese?
Ich gucke gerade nochmal nach.
Ist der Morbis Hodgkin wichtig?
Hat er etwas damit zu tun?
Nach meiner Spissens, ich weiß es nicht ganz genau,
aber die beide sind plastische Krankheiten über ein orthologisches System.
Und was kann sein?
Was kann sein?
Ich meine, der hat ja wegen Morbis Hodgkin damals Chemo-Tapie und Bestrahlung bekommen, ja?
Kann das sein, dass das damit zusammenhängt?
Also, johni-synistralen sind Risikofaktor für Myolom, ja?
Das kann sein, dass es nicht spätfolge auch sein kann, aber es ist spekulativ, ja?
Aber könnte Hinweis sein, ja?
Johni-synistralen.
Gut, jetzt haben wir noch eine Zeit.
Jetzt wollten Sie etwas zur Diagnostik sagen, ja?
Vielleicht machen wir noch 1 Minuten Diagnostik.
Ja, Elektrophoräse ist wichtig, diese Paraproteine ist so entdeckt.
Richtig, genau.
Was ist, wenn Sie Elektrophoräse machen und es sieht normal aus, oder Sie haben keine...
Dann sollte ein Knochenmarkt, wie ob Sie durchgeführt werden.
Richtig, ja, genau.
Was sehen Sie im Knochenmarkt, haben Sie schon gesagt?
Ja, wir können diese Paraproteine sehen, diese Produktion, oder wir können...
Das können Sie im Knochenmarkt nicht sehen, dann normalen Verabungen nicht.
Was sehen Sie im Knochenmarkt, warum behan Sie den Knochenmarkt?
Ja, ob die ganze Körper, die Blutzellen richtig produziert, die Verteilung, die Entwicklung.
Richtig.
Und vor allen Dingen, haben Sie gesagt, ist es eine Krankheit von welchen Zellen?
Plasmacellen, ja, können wir vermehrte Plasmacellen sehen.
Ja, genau, ja.
Was ist das Kriterium für einen Myolom?
Wie viel Prozent?
Das Knochenmarkt muss Plasmacellen sein, damit Sie am Myolom Diagnose stellen können.
Leider krank ich mich nicht.
Ja, ich bin oft Almolo genügend, das ist so viel für mich.
Das ist dann nicht schwierig, ja.
Also mindestens 10%, dann können Sie das, das ist ein Kriterium, ja.
Wenn es weniger ist, ist es nicht ausgeschlossen, aber bei mehr als 10% können Sie das die Diagnose stellen.
Ja, gut.
Also Sie haben einen Knochenmarkt gemacht, aber ich noch mal zur Elektrophorese.
Da sehen Sie ja diese Immun, also Sie sehen ja die Globuline, Immunglobulin, da sehen Sie manchmal so einen monoklonalen Pieck.
Aber wenn Sie da jetzt nicht sehen, was kann trotzdem dahinterstecken,
wenn es ein Myolom ist, ein multibes Myolom ist, was kann man dann noch bestimmen, im Blut?
Sehr spät ist jetzt Hematologie, aber wenn es einmal gehört haben, ist es nicht verkehrt.
Was produzieren Sie?
Normalerweise produzieren diese Plasmacen ja Immunglobuline, ja.
Immunglobuline, und das Immunglobuline sind ja so y-förmige Moleküle, ja,
die stehen aus grob zwei Komponenten oder, naja, nicht dabei aus wichtigen zwei Komponenten,
das sind einmal die Schwerketten und die Leichtketten, ja.
Und manchmal produzieren diese bösen Zellen nicht komplett Immunglobuline, sondern Teile davon.
Und dann sehen Sie in der Elektrophorese nichts, aber Sie können im Blut eine erhöhte Wert von den Leichtketten zum Beispiel sehen.
Leichtkettenproduktion, das ist auch das, was zum Beispiel auch die Niere schädigt, ja, Leichtketten.
Also es gibt manchmal Leichtketten, Miolome.
Gut, also Sie haben jetzt Elektrophorese gemacht, Knochenmax-Punktion.
Was sehen Sie sonst in den Laborwerten?
Was ist noch wichtig für die Diagnose Miolome?
Eins haben Sie schon gesagt, das ist die Anämiegel.
Was kann noch sein?
Im Chat schreiben die Kollegen schon fleißig.
Haben Sie gelesen?
Ja.
DSG, ich habe auch gehört, ja, richtig.
Aber wenn Sie jetzt mal einen Differenzialblutbild machen, also Sie sehen eine Anämie, was gibt es noch?
Haben Sie auch schon gesagt?
Ja, wir können auch Lacosteopinne und Trombostopinne sehen.
Also Panstopinne sehen?
Ja, genau, genau.
Und dann haben die Kollegen noch etwas geschrieben, was wichtig ist bei Miolome, ja.
Hyperkalzämie, also Kalzumkonstigen.
Ja, wegen Osteolysis.
Und wegen der Niere, die Nieren-Kritenzionsparameter, sprich Kreatin, Haarstoff und so weiter, angestiegen sein.
Das sind die Kriterien, die man normalerweise verwendet für die Diagnose Multi-Bismiologe.
Okay, gut, das war jetzt sehr viel Spezialwissen.
Ja.
Aber trotzdem haben Sie es...
Ja, das war sehr hilfreich.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, manchmal muss man auch so bisschen die Pathophysiologie mit der Kopfhabe,
und man kann es anders als das fragen, warum ist das jetzt so, erzählen Sie mal.
Und wenn Sie jetzt schon lange nichts mehr von gehört haben, von Physiologin Biochemie,
ist es nochmal wichtig zu wiederholen, glaube ich.
Gut, gibt es aus dem Chat noch Kommentare oder Fragen?
Wenn nicht, würde ich das nämlich heute dann beenden.
Ich glaube...
Sie haben jetzt eine Grafik genutzt, wie ist es jetzt?
Herrmann?
Sie haben eine sehr genutzt, wie ist es jetzt?
Ermittelt ihr es?
Herrmann?
Es geht schon, wie lange ist es?
Vor 100 Jahren?
27 Jahre, oder so?
Nein, vor 20 Jahren war es auch nicht so.
Das Problem mit der Syndikraft ist nicht so sensitiv.
Vor 20 Jahren war es auch noch so.
Die Syndikraft ist normalerweise nicht genutzt, wie es ist.
Wir haben einen Röntgen, den wir nach der Synthikraft vorgekommen haben.
Die Stimulatur wurde in den letzten Jahren verstanden.
Aber wir haben die Röntgen und die Synthikraft genutzt.
Dann ist es ein Problem, glaube ich.
Vor 20 Jahren war es auch nicht so, wie die Syndikraft ist.
Röntgen, CT oder MR.
Die Synthikraft ist jetzt noch sehr stark.
Wir haben vorhin gemacht, dass wir MR Spine machen.
Wir haben vorhin gesagt, dass wir MR Spine machen.
Und wir haben vorhin gemacht, dass wir MR Spine machen.
Das ist ein Problem, das wir vorhin gemacht haben.
Ihr habt es sehr gut gemacht.
Ihr habt auch die Sprache über die Sprache.
Das war sehr gut.
Vielen Dank.
Wie lange habt ihr die Möglichkeit?
Ein paar Monate.
Okay, ihr habt mehr Zeit.
Ihr könnt jetzt auch noch mal in die Sprache gehen.
Vielen Dank.
Danke.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen einen guten Abend.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen guten Abend.
Vielen Dank.